ainsi que je rigole que j'ai disparu
[Musique]
il
est vivant
[Musique]
mais c'est incroyable c'est à dire
qu'elle le garde 48 heures ça
incroyable cissé avait cessé ses trucs
et après c'est vrai que c'est comme
quand vous vous casser le bras montrer
comme ça veut forcément
enfin et le média trophée c'est juste le
muscle qui font c'est un coin est ce que
vous trouvez que cette technique est
irresponsable petitement garde oui assez
choquants et honteux ils sont suivis par
un public est très jeune ça les incite à
faire ça moi sinon ça m'énervait que les
influenceurs c'est qu'ils nous
expliquent qu'on absout sans rien faire
on devient riche sans rien faire on
maigrit sans rien faire il ferait mieux
de mettre en avant l'effort mais c'est
vrai nom mais après après si c'est leur
truc après moi je moi je je sais que ça
c'est dangereux mais je pense pas
qu'elle se rende compte de ça bien sûr
les allées qui vendent des produits ces
bagarres mais là ça touche à la santé
comme ya des dangers c'est dangereux ils
sont responsables en faisant cette
responsabilité at il alors c'est cher
d'abord un 90 euros la séance ensuite
y'a aucune certitude 90 euros la séance
spéciale le plâtre en institut voilà
parce que ça se développe en institut ya
quelques instituts qui le font en france
mais non normalement un institut on n'a
pas le droit de le faire mais on a neuf
de plâtre cgfr j'ai vu les publicités
aujourd'hui 90 euros la séance donc est
en fait le problème c'est qu'il ya
aucune certitude sur l'efficacité et il
ya même des médecins qui disent que ça
pourrait être cancérigène
donc en fait c'est vrai que ça vient de
colombie pour moi franchement elle ne
devrait pas se lancer là-dedans classés
de la responsable oui pardon mais elle
se rend compte évidemment qu'elles
seront que du cynisme en fait c'est
juste pour faire du buzz et donc on va
en parler c'est dangereux assurant par
là non moi je pense qu'elles sont en
france pas franchement c'est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est dangereux mathieu à
bessines avait bien aimé qu'elle le
fasse c'est très dangereux après c'est
vrai c'est limite d'instagram ou tut tut
tut tut étudie une insulte et en coupe
ton compte et là moi j'ai vu tellement
de choses enfin moi à l'époque on me
demandait quand j'étais payé pour ce
truc-là de de vendre des coupe faim
qu'on n'avait pas essayé du tout là
c'est très dangereux aussi je me suis un
habitat qui avait utilisé aux gens
achetaient des bitcoins bon je dis c'est
là le pouvoir qu'on donne à ces gens là
je rejoins effectivement guillaume c'est
vrai alors moi j'aime pas le fait de
dire s'ils ont la chaîne pas le mets sur
le type qui jouera que je me suis en
mairie alors c'est j'aime pas ce côté
péjoratif c'est un filon larmes et m'a
dit c'est non mais besser oui mais alors
influent sur c'est un métier aujourd'hui
je suis à la visite et responsable que
oui là en l'occurrence
franchement appartement ou où ça touche
le corps le corps la restructuration la
santé le paramédical ça devrait être
totalement encadré c'est à dire qu'on
aurait on devrait pas avoir le droit de
d'être sur instagram snaps ya tout autre
sur des sujets qui sont telles que le
médical le paramédical la santé ça
devrait être totalement interdits il
devrait y avoir une législation là
dessus après on fait ce qu'on veut si on
veut vendre un un pull un je ne sais pas
quoi mais en revanche sur le médical et
paramédical devrait totalement encadré
non vraiment moi pour moi le plâtre on
m'a toujours dit que c'était pour
consolider un muscle pour immobiliser
immobilisé un os un os non mais d'accord
un os mais j'ai compris ce que je
voulais dire pas non hélas ce qu'elle
fait là quand elle dit
raconte ce qu'elle fait mais si elles
seront bien sûr la puissance des réseaux
sociaux jusqu'à l'été venu justement ici
pour une histoire qu'il avait foutu dans
la merde avec les réseaux sociaux le
maire la puissance cas là elle sait très
bien qu'elle peut parler à des jeunes
pourquoi il a dit gilles boulet dont le
prix de la 10 mois genre pad il pris
pour 90 euros franchement les gens et
loyal et ils vont dire j'y vais c'est
sur cette génération passée run mais
cette génération c'est je pense qu'elle
fait même pas ça pour l'argent pour
c'est que toutes ces générations
maintenant quand tu viens un peu avec
eux toute la journée c'est coucou je
suis en train de manger coucou je vais
lâcher dans une loge c'est d'écrire mes
lordi en permanence nationale ça ils
pensaient
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
est-ce qu il ya des sondages ou pas ou
pas encore
droit et demain demain je vous dirai
pourquoi les sondages avaient disparu
c'est un truc incroyable qui s'est passé
dans des pmp je vous dirai dans
l'émission demain demain l'émission sera
d'ailleurs en direct demain vendredi à
ses services et 84 à 6%